bueno esto además que es un líder
carismático con mucha llegada popular
como decía el informe se crió él en un
barrio muy humilde la teja del recordaba
siempre los valores de su familia esa
casa de lata en donde creció pero que le
permitió ir a la universidad graduarse
de médico y luego basar su extensa
carrera política en la vocación social
él hizo mucho énfasis en justamente dar
de vuelta a los más pobres como decíamos
en 1989 logra primero la intendencia de
la capital de uruguay montevideo así
consolida al frente amplio esta fuerza
social de izquierda en el 2005 y 2015 es
presidente haciendo énfasis en el
trabajo social recibe un país con un 40
por ciento de pobreza y en ese momento
comenzaba como presidente teniendo el
apoyo popular de un 80 por ciento hizo
énfasis en las políticas de salud
la cobertura a todos los ciudadanos
también en la educación logrando que los
niños de educación primaria obtengan
acceso a internet y también una tableta
para acceder justamente a internet luego
en la lucha contra el tabaco y al que
los llevó a una lucha legal de
muchísimos años incluso con una de las
tabacaleras philip morris allí el
presidente lo logró ganar esa batalla y
también instaurar que en uruguay sea el
séptimo país en el mundo en prohibir el
consumo de cigarrillos en lugares
públicos e incluso la publicidad de lo
mismo también el veto al aborto fue otro
de los puntos que destacaron su carrera
política para terminar la despedida será
por supuesto acorde a los tiempos de
pandemia verdad tenemos entendido que ya
se convocó para las 21 horas que suenen
en todos los hogares uruguayos la
canción defender la alegría que es la
versión cantada por joan manuel serrat
del poema de mario benedetti y también
cinco minutos de aplausos verdad
en otros actos también
así es esos cinco minutos de aplausos a
las 21 horas pero ya los aplausos están
escuchando por los pasados 20 minutos
desde que salió justamente el consejo
fúnebre desde la intendencia de
montevideo si bien los cepillos fueron
privados se está ahora en este momento
es el traslado del cuerpo hacia el
cementerio de la teja también lo sigue
una caravana extensa de vehículos la
familia pidió y también el frente amplio
pidió a la población que no se acercara
pero sin embargo muchas personas están
acercándose en las aceras y siguiendo
este con justamente el cortejo fúnebre
de que llegara al cementerio de la teja